hey let nothing about motivates that oh
I really like Matt Reeves and has set up
for I mean it's an interesting direction
I don't think it's it's something from
the comics which hasn't been really
exported yeah yeah it's kind of crazy
shoes to fill
I mean it's interesting what the
different directions you can take with
it in the kind of foot in some was quite
a specific character there's actually
quite a lot of leeway I mean when you
look at the different tones of all these
movies I mean and the TV shows I mean
you can do quite a lot with it yeah me
like that one was really that the only
kind of superhero who I really had any
kind of connection with when I was
growing up oh yeah I don't I'm really
yeah from the from the Tim Burton ones I
mean I just kind of obsessed I was a kid
and it's very very very daunting it's
weird I'm quite glad I'm doing Christmas
movie right now cuz I I got something
else to be nervous about
I haven't got enough anxiety space in my
head to really get a too anxious about
it yeah so I'm kind of quite happily
just like figuring out how to do things
without without really think about the
pressure yet
where were you when you learned that you
were gonna be a sling I think my first
day with Chris Nolan just saying
that has old funny
he's the back like his his is the best
and like it's kind of I mean it's
definitely unlike anything I've ever
worked I have actually started the year
without a job okay way free you know I
feel like I've never really had the
opportunity to like just say oh I want
to do this and then it just happens I've
made it clear to director so I want to
work with you know if you ever have
anything I'll drop everything and do it
with you but like you can be on Indies
and those doing this movie waiting for
the barbarians and ended up being
Morocco for months and own tons and tons
of days off them between my just when I
was shooting which is kind of what it
feels like my studio movie I meant
something at the Lighthouse like you
were just like it's just every minute
today like late working till the 6th of
the morning things things change very
quickly sometimes hey everybody it's
Charlie's surprise surprise Robert
Pattinson teasing all kinds of details
about the Batman Matt Reeves movie is
actually gonna be a trilogy so he says a
whole lot more than what's in that clip
so we'll break it all down it's been a
very Batman character kind of week
because we had the birds of prey trailer
yesterday then both of my Joker videos a
couple days before that but if they're
getting ready to start shooting the
Batman movie and casting the rest of his
supporting cast like Catwoman the
Riddler penguin then it makes total
sense that they would use this
opportunity to hype up Robert Pattinson
'he's new Batman movie we're doing a
movie ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best new Robert Pattinson Batman
theory on the video the really funny
thing that happened while I was making
this video is Tom Holland released a
separate spider-man video during that he
totally stands Robert Pattinson 'he's
Batman here's the clip of that how could
we talk wallaby at playing Batman well I
wouldn't be as good as my friend robber
person he's gonna kill it as Batman I
don't even know if that's actually true
is he actually playing Batman he is
that's sick he's gonna kill it and I
wouldn't want to go up against him
because he's a bit of a beast with great
power comes quick
sponsibility are you doing Batman well
uh sure okay that's not even the right
cinematic universe as funny as that is
the larger Robert Pattinson interview
was done with variety so we'll just go
down the list breaking down all the
important stuff from that also fun fact
he said that he talked to Marvel a
couple years ago about playing a
character in the MCU but nothing ever
came of it I think I know which
character he's talking about so I'll
mention that at the end of the video
after I talk about the Batman movie
stuff but really funny he starts out
talking about how he learned that he won
the Batman role while he was on set for
his first day working with Christopher
Nolan
mr. Dark Knight trilogy himself on the
brand new tenant movie that's the new
movie with John David Washington and
that special teaser that they only
released in theaters you may have heard
about the secret new teaser for the
Christopher Nolan movie that no one is
allowing to be posted online Warner
Brothers keeps taking it down every time
someone tries to post it on social media
Robert Pattinson is playing a character
during that that'll air sometime after
Wonder Woman 1984 next summer so we'll
see Robert Pattinson in a Christopher
Nolan movie fun Batman tangent before we
see him in the actual Batman movie which
is supposed to come out summer 2021 he
said that he wore the Batman suit
already he didn't say which bat suit he
didn't say they were costume testing for
his new version of the Batman suit or if
he was wearing someone's old Batman suit
because if you've ever seen any of the
auditions from Ben Affleck or Christian
Bale's Batman audition they both wore
Val Kilmer's Batman suit during their
screen tests this is actually a clip of
Christian Bale auditioning for Batman
Begins in val kilmer suit it's not who I
am underneath
but what I do that defines me trouble
nothing I can handle he knows he was at
the docks he won't talk he'll talk to me
Falcone at the docks no no I swear to
god swear if you look really closely you
can pry see him sweating boas through
that suit because the auditions take
forever in it's super hot on that set
Robert Pattinson is quote about the
actual bat suit he wore though just said
you do feel very powerful immediately
and it's pretty astonishing something
that is incredibly difficult to get into
physically so the ritual of actually
getting into it is pretty humiliating
you got five people trying to shove you
into something and once you got it on
it's like yeah I feel strong I feel
tough even though I had to have someone
squeeze my butt cheeks into the legs
he makes special note of the fact that
the way that they're making the new
Batman movie in the story they're
telling is something that no one has
ever done before in previous Batman
films he's mostly talking about doing a
younger Batman but not necessarily
redoing the origin story in a linear way
like Christopher Nolan did during Batman
Begins he's born parents die he screws
off to the League of Assassins for
training then returns to Gotham to take
the mantle of the bat the new Batman is
meant to be a mid twenty-something
Batman who's still pretty early in his
career but it's not Frank Miller Batman
year one reportedly the story is a more
literal adaptation of long Halloween and
dark victory which as he says has not
been done in the movies before other
Batman films have borrowed elements from
long Halloween but no one has
straight-up tried to do a long Halloween
movie if you're a longtime comic book
fan though you know that dark victory is
the sequel story too long Halloween in
haunted night is kind of the third story
in that long Halloween trilogy we
learned a little while ago that Matt
Reeves is supposed to be doing a new
Batman trilogy so it makes sense that
they would adapt those three different
stories or elements from those stories
for the next three Batman films they
won't be literal page to screen
adaptations just in the way that
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
was inspired by a lot of classic Batman
comics like The Killing Joke Joker's
five-way Revenge Batman year one but
they weren't literal page to screen
adaptations fun fact to Christopher
Nolan also revealed that he borrowed a
little bit from Batman the long
Halloween for Dark Knight
is one of the most iconic Batman stories
of all time so of course everyone's
gonna borrow a little from it there were
people inside Warner Brothers that were
describing earlier versions of the
script as being a version of Batman mask
of the phantasm with a few different
characters but I think the idea is that
because he's doing a detective thriller
style Batman movie it'll be much more on
the tone of that even if they don't
borrow a whole lot of story elements
from mask of the phantasm right now the
rumored rogues gallery is Selena Kyle
Catwoman the penguin the Riddler
two-face Mad Hatter in Firefly no word
on who's playing those characters but
there was a rumor circulating that
Vanessa Kirby was one of the top picks
for Catwoman she was just in Hobson's
shop but I liked her better during
Mission Impossible fallout a long time
ago there were also some rumors about a
Robin appearing in the movie but unless
Matt Reeves comes out or someone with
the movie and clarifies I don't think
there's gonna be Robin during this movie
they're still trying to make that
Nightwing movie but with the way things
are looking it probably won't happen for
like six or seven years because they're
expecting Robert Pattinson Batman
trilogy to blow up huge in the problem
they have with that is that his Batman
is so young so in a couple years when
they eventually get to the sequel and
he's still really young and Robin would
still be really young if they eventually
introduced him during the trilogy that
creates all kinds of timeline chaos and
confusion for the casual non comic book
fan audience that's gonna make up the
majority of the box office for these new
movies so if you're wondering why
they're sitting on that Nightwing movie
and you haven't heard anything about it
it's probably because they're expecting
these new Batman movies to be so big we
had Nightwing on Titans anyway this
season so if you want to see some
Nightwing just keep watching Titans on
the DC streaming service but for those
of you asking which Marvel character was
Robert Pattinson talking to them about
well it was around the time they were
getting ready to make James Gunn's
guardians of the galaxy so I think there
was a brief period right after the
Twilight movies ended where they were
talking to him about possibly being
their Peter quill star-lord because
around the time he would have been
auditioning for them that's the only
real character that he would have fit in
terms of age there weren't that many
other younger people everybody post her
theories about the Batman movie on the
video I'll do more videos as we get more
details and they start releasing more
information I just did a video for that
viral birds-of-prey trailer I'm
expecting a bigger version of that to
post online sometime in the next couple
days so while you wait for everything
click here to rewatch that birds-of-prey
trailer and click here for my
non-spoilery joker movie review thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]